my killer hello everybody and welcome
back to another video in titanfall to
today's we are going to be talking about
the Colosseum playlist and before we get
started I just like to say I'm sorry for
not uploading in the past week something
was [ __ ] up with my computer but I
ended up getting it fixed so we're all
good everything's all taken care of so
we're back in business boys but we're
talking about the Colosseum playlist
today the Colosseum is a 1v1 game mode
set on one little platform that's kind
of like in case then like a cylinders
you can wall run on it basically you
face another player in a 1v1
best-of-five so the first person to
three wins now each player spawns with
an EPG or the electronic pulse grenade
launcher I think that's how you
pronounce it and you also come with a
charger I flies or secondary you get a
frag grenade and you also have the phase
shift ability the only the only problem
with the Colosseum game mode is that you
need Colosseum tickets the only way to
get Colosseum tickets or three different
ways that I know of one you get them by
advocate gifts and from what I can
remember the only way to get an advocate
gift is you rank up your faction like to
get like a level one if you rank up
let's say the apex predators to rank
from Rank 1 to 2 you can add forget gift
and but there's a chance that it will
come with a Coliseum ticket there I
think there's a couple levels also like
somewhere in the mid game where you also
do get a Coliseum ticket the second way
you can get them is by getting doing
doritos this sounds really weird and
trust me I've this is the one way I got
the Colosseum tickets if you buy a
mountain dew or you buy Doritos on the
on the bag or on the bottle as a code
and you can plug that into doing Doritos
calm for titanfall 2 and you can get a
Coliseum ticket as long as some other
prizes like an execution or an eye on
war paint the third way you can do it is
by paying through credits
you can buy Coliseum tickets for 10 uh
credits I know that doesn't seem like a
lot but since you don't really get much
as it is or at least I don't really know
how to get much it's kind of a struggle
really so I only played like a few
Coliseum matches overall the game mode
isn't that bad not a lot of people play
it seeing as there's no like you can
just go in and play no matter what you
have to have a ticket but regardless
that's basically it that's how to get
into the coliseum you're going to be
seeing gameplay as I talk over this just
to get the feel of what it looks like
but uh thank you all for sticking with
it I stick until the end of the video
I'm very happy with the results that I
were getting on the past two videos
regarding titanfall 2 so I think I'm
gonna stick to more titanfall if you
want me to cover more games please tell
me in the comments below but like the
video if you enjoyed and subscribe if
you're new for more titanfall videos
every once or twice now within the week
or so but regardless guys peace have a
great day